Bà hôi 20,5,5,5,5,5 trong quá trình kinh trà nửa độ côn.
Mát tý tại đường hoàn Quốc Việt phương Umbi, tổ công tác số 5 phối hợp với tổ cơ động số
tám thuộc độ cạnh sất xiao thông đường bộ số 1.
Phong cạnh sất xiao thông công an tình quán ninh ra hiệu lệnh với xe ô tô tại 11.2 2,
sau bốn dí trình và lạnh kinh trà.
Lại xe không chức thành mà điều khiến phương tị lấy khỏi hàng,
tăng ra bỏ trẻ theo vững phượng vàng dành.
Ngay sau đó, lực lượng trức năng đã sự dụng xe công vụ tiếp cận,
đồng thời gian tiểu đọc ra yêu cầu phương tịn dừng lại.
Như lệ xe không nghĩ không chức thành mà còn tích tục điều khiến xe vào trong ó nhằm chung tránh việc kinh trà.
Hí xe của lực lượng cạnh sất xiao thông a sát,
lệ xe tải đã cho xe lùi lại và vá trạm vào xe công vụ.
Lâm đàn chiều xác bên phải nước bớt,
giữ tích tục bỏ trẻ được khoảng 1 kêu mát thị bị lực lượng chức năng không chế.
Khi quá kinh trà bà đầu rất định,
vui điều khiến phương tị lấy 5 vét tê,
xin 5 bùng in chính trăm chỉ mì mốt,
chú phương quan hành, khoảng ninh, người nguyên bình cảnh là lâu tên đi,
xin 5 bùng in chính trăm chỉ mì bày chú phương cầm phá, khoảng ninh.
Khi quá kinh trà nừng đổ quân cho thấy trong hơi thở của tê
có nừng đổ quân khu vệ 2 khô khô mì lây gàm chế lý khí thở.
Hẹn khó quan chức năng đăng tích tục khoảng tịn hồ sơ để xưa lĩnh nghiênh theo quy định.